[Musica]
ora sera noi siamo qui per raccontarvi
una storia una storia di qualcosa che
prima non c'era cinéma du desert un
cinema solare itinerante tutto nasce nel
2009 quando io con david è uno dei
fondatori di questo progetto
partiamo però un viaggio destinazione
africa
avevamo deciso di dare un di più a
questo viaggio e quindi nel mare delle
organizzazioni contattiamo
l'organizzazione non governativa bambini
nel deserto
viaggiavamo a bordo di un camion campo
rizzato e lo vorrei avevamo riempire il
più possibile di materiale da consegnare
a progetti di questa organizzazione in
africa
e fu così parti tutto e proprio durante
una delle prime consegne eravamo
talmente stupiti e così piacevolmente
sconvolti dall'accoglienza la generosità
di questo popolo in un piccolo villaggio
del mali che volevamo fare qualcosa per
contro a cambiargli e li abbiamo deciso
di fare un regalo non materiale abbiamo
issato lo schermo cinematografico acceso
le luci del proiettore e come per magia
sotto le stelle fucine va a me io
personalmente volevo proprio guardare
con i miei occhi
cos'è questa storia della povertà
africane che spesso si parla quindi per
forza sono andato con loro sono andato
in giro fino a burkina faso 16 mille
chilometri il phenom consiglio
portoghese con un game al mezzo con sé
italiani chiusi dentro da un camion che
era anche una casa che era anche un
ufficio abbiamo fatto tutta questa
strada
cosa ho imparato in cinque mesi io
personalmente ho imparato che poi poi a
prendere molto di più quando la zona di
conforto vaghi e quando la zona di
sicurezza va lì e quando non sai quando
non fai il turismo che porti porti la
forma con vvv to laggiù ho anche
imparato che era un grande contro
assenso fare utilizzare la benzina
mentre facevamo vedere tutti questi
documentari sui problemi ecologici
quindi piano piano e mo lottato e fatto
tanti fund raising per creare un
impianto voltaico sopra il camion quindi
adesso almeno il cambio non inquina
grazie al sole possiamo continuare a
fare vedere i nostri film cerco questo è
uno dei nostri presupposti noi trattiamo
vari tipi di tematiche con i nostri film
e documentari
alcuni sono del mainstream e altri sono
autoprodotti da noi è una delle quello
dell'ecologia era uno dei temi per noi
importanti
insomma dopo i primi viaggi possiamo
assolutamente affermare che il mal
d'africa esiste ci siamo già ritornati
quattro volte fino in burkina faso di a
terra e poi nel corso degli anni e
proseguiamo perché dappertutto c'è
bisogno di condivisione dappertutto c'è
bisogno di stare insieme di riflettere
di sorridere anche in italia dove siamo
stati siamo stati da poco in grecia nei
campi profughi nei campi profughi
dappertutto il cinema desserts serve
perché tutti insieme stiamo lì e
guardiamo lo stesso orizzonte dai perché
non andare ancora più lontano perché non
andare fino mongolia che proprio lontane
per terra in un camion che non fa più
del 60 chilometri orari
quindi 29 mille chilometri andata e
ritorno 9 mesi si nove mesi
ho ancora provato a riflettere insieme
queste situazioni di emergenza che
stiamo vivendo adesso in questo nuovo
ammirare le mondo con cui forse il
ultimi nomadi mongoli e perché tutto sta
cambiando così che logiche non si sa non
si sa cosa succederà fra un po ed ecco
continuiamo così appunto viaggiamo a
bordo di un camion da un deserto
all'altro dall'europa dell'est e
dell'ovest non riusciamo più a stare
fermi il camion e auto costruito e
abbiamo creato il da cellula
abbiamo fatto una comparazione che ci
permette di vivere di cucinare
all'interno è la nostra casa il nostro
ufficio e abbiamo un'ampia zona carico
dove carichiamo tutto il materiale per
il cinema è anche quello che a volte
dobbiamo consegnare pre dei progetti ad
oggi 21 paesi in tre continenti 100.000
km e decine migliaia di persone
incontrate e credo che da questa foto si
possa capire che ne vale la pena
il cinema delle serre arriva quasi
sempre come una sorpresa e raramente ci
annunciamo arriviamo parcheggiamo
parliamo con lo chef del villaggio e
chiediamo il permesso per fare delle
proiezioni
tutto comincia giocando con noi viaggia
anche un castello gonfiabile
quindi facciamo uscire i giochi e un po
di animazione per i più piccoli
passeggiamo con i nostri cani fedeli
compagni di vita di viaggio e poi
attendiamo che cali la notte per
accendere le luci del proiettore e
regalare noti di magia sotto le stelle è
sicuramente e felicità ed eccoci passano
gli anni
sono tantissime le cose che vi potremo
raccontare emozioni da trasmettere
ricordi
certo abbiamo fatto cinema per due
persone dentro un agli urti e mongolia
ma anche per migliaia di persone in
africa
che dire posso raccontarvi di quelle due
signori avrà avuto sulla sessantina
avevo già sentito parlare di televisione
ma non avevano mai visto mega schermo
oppure quel pescatore che dopo aver
visto un documentario ci viene a dire mi
sembrava di stare seduto sulla mia
piroga e da lì vedere scorrere tutto il
mondo intero davanti ai miei occhi anche
sembrato di vivere un film nel film
perché c'è anche chi scappa da davanti
allo schermo perché ha paura che
l'immagine possa uscire colpirli quindi
ripeto tante cose che diamo per scontato
è bello stupire ed è bello emozionarci
insieme anche grasse delle pellicole
appunto crediamo fondamentale irridere
perché base del benessere della persona
ma ci piace anche riflettere
sono tante le tematiche che scegliamo e
scegliamo con cure documentari film e li
porti a seconda del luogo dove stiamo
delle popolazioni che andremo incontrare
usiamo principalmente produzione non
verbali riusciamo così a superare il gap
linguistico e creiamo dei ponti tra
culture diverse questo è un po il nostro
obiettivo e poi da lì riusciamo
intessere relazioni di fiducia e quando
è possibile o quando è necessario
cerchiamo di sviluppare progetti di
cooperazione e solidarietà a me mi ha
sempre stupito completamente come nel
ciclo 21 un'idea così semplice può avere
questo questo potere questo impatto
forse incommensurabili diciamo e mamma
magari questo nostro discorso fino
adesso vi ha lasciato curiosi per sapere
di più
ma anche anche motivati per agire
anargiri ancora ancora di più perché io
personalmente ho sempre avuto questa
necessità che non lo so non lo so detto
vi arriva questa necessità di scambiare
le forse aiutare ma proprio mettermi al
la scarpe degli altri e questo mondo e
proprio molto complesso e ancora sempre
più connesso comunque cinema del deserto
è un progetto senza scopo di senza scopo
di lucro
quindi non è non è facile andare avanti
con un progetto che in teoria non farà i
soldi e comunque per per quello è per i
volontari che ringraziamo che possiamo
andare avanti ancora che vanno con o in
viaggio a fare vedere i cinema gratis
sotto le stelle per tanti tanti mesi ci
regalano il suo tempo devo dire che
torniamo il viaggio fra un paio di
settimana quarta volte come ha detto
francesca e quarta volta andiamo giù a
burkina faso e magari anche riusciamo a
tornare ai campi di rifugiati di grecia
perché è proprio una crisi umanitaria
umana che sta succedendo vicino a casa
nostra è lì lì del cinema all sfogo può
essere anche può essere proprio il
potere vero che la gente si sente un po
più umana quando la speranza è un po
nascosta e quindi sia un progetto che
parte dal basso che parte da un sogno
che è diventato realtà
sette anni itinerando con un cinema
solare come diceva siamo pronti di nuovo
la ripartenza e
e questa sera pensavamo si noi portiamo
in giro un cinema ma anche lo facciamo
gioco è un antropologo vittoria per
esempio è proprio questa sera vorremmo
condividere con voi un'anteprima
un'anteprima che tocca e parla di un
tema che ci sta molto a cuore
e come dire
immaginiamoci di essere nel buio nel
buio profondo del deserto e partiamo
insieme per un piccolo grande viaggio
perché il cambio climatico ha un
problema ti ricordi quando è stata
l'ultima volta che non ci sia battuto un
record per la temperatura più alta anche
perché siamo sinceri è veramente
difficile avere una visione d'insieme ma
tutti questi sono sintomi della stessa
malattia
la sfida più grande che la nostra specie
dovrà affrontare nei prossimi decenni è
il cambio climatico causato dall'uomo ma
perché preoccuparsi perché preoccuparsi
del cambio climatico e forse gli orsi
polari sono destinati a scomparire
[Musica]
e questo è molto triste ma non è solo
per gli orsi polari
dobbiamo e smetterla con questo
complesso di superiorità che ci fa
credere di essere separati della natura
e questi il nostro punto quello di
salvare la natura la natura stessa
dall'inevitabile catastrofi dei
cambiamenti climatici e che noi siamo
natura
viviamo dentro a questo ecosistema e
quindi dovremo agire in quanto parte di
esso per salvare noi stessi
perché questo è quello che probabilmente
accadrà nei prossimi decenni le risorse
diventeranno sempre più scarse
ci sarà sempre meno acqua e dunque meno
cibo come le temperature saliranno
termina balzerano a cio che veramente mi
preoccupa solo di polita che
sopravvivono dell'area sussistenza
appena il camp ultima cambierà beh
allora questi popoli non potrà note
migrare bene così inizieremo anche di
immigrazione di massa e che in
cominceremo a parlare dei rifugiati
climatici
[Musica]
certo possiamo continuare a cercare di
riciclare istituiti più utilizzare gli
aerei sempre di meno ma questo non basta
perché questo non ci porterà a
migliorare la nostra società ad
adattarsi ai cambiamenti climatici
né tantomeno a ridurli
quello di qui abbiamo davvero bisogno è
più formazione una formazione che ho io
l'intenzione di chiamare educazione
climatica proprio così perché
l'educazione da alle persone agli
strumenti per distinguere tra lecci alde
buone e utili per loro stesse e quelli
negativi e questo non è facile un mondo
in cui i media sono gestiti dalle stesse
organizzazioni che hanno interessi
opposti a quelli delle persone
abbiamo da esempi positivi a qui
possiamo guardare
[Musica]
come possiamo fare per la formazione
e come agire
la nostra scelta è stata quella di
viaggiare
condividere la magia del cinema con le
persone offrendo
il libero accesso alla quinta perché
crediamo che l'educazione sia un
pilastro fondamentale per la dignità
umana ci connettiamo con popolazioni che
non ho mai visto un'immagine in
movimento nella loro vita
abbiamo incontrato persone che non
avevano mai visto l'oceano e che non
conoscevano di animali che dentro ci
abitano altri non avevano mai visto
alice nel paese delle meraviglie o cia
ricerche cose che noi diamo per scontati
cerchiamo di condividere insieme a loro
una bella esperienza
facciamo del 2009 abbiamo viaggiato in
più di 21 paesi diversi continenti più
di 100.000 chilometri percorsi e
continueremo a farlo perché anche se
cambiamo in meglio la vita è una sola
persona
crediamo che ne valga la pena
finché continueremo consumare risorse da
tutto il mondo e chiamarla come
valutazione
possiamo dire di essere tutti sulla
stessa barca
e questa barca è il pianeta terra
se davvero vogliamo fermare i
cambiamenti climatici
dobbiamo cominciare cambiando noi stessi
grazie a spettanti
[Musica]